Relationships,
you know,
they,
what they do is me taking fragile piece and I actually think that probably works
if you're,
if you're bounded by roles.
And this was a union observation.
So Yoga belief that you didn't have to have an individual relationship if you
were in a traditional culture because women did women phase and then did men
things and they walked along the path in parallel and there were no conflicts
because there were no their word.
But you know,
they're there.
Most of what you were supposed to do was laid out for you.
And you know,
modern people don't like that idea,
but just trying to go shooting over who should do,
who should cook dinner,
see if you can settle that before you make a decision about whether the rules
are useful or not.
Cause you know,
I'd be in lots of houses where that fight,
it'd been going on for 35 years.
Never solved.
So hitch could need neo was,
the food was terrible.
The husband and wife were at each other's throats,
you know,
fine.
So it's really hard once you're under the rules to,
once you're out of the rules,
you have to do it as an individual.
But that's a trek,
tremendous demand.
It's an unbelievable demand.
It's the same demand that essentially the Dostoyevsky put on himself.
It's like we're partners will say,
you are one weird and unwieldy and malevolent and peculiar creature and so
alive.
So like how the hell are we going to sort that out?
Well,
you better be awake if you're going to sort that out and they fuck you all heard
of him is the Gottman situation,
right?
Everything's fine and your heart's racing and your cordisol is generating and
you know you're having murderous streams.
I've had clients who were very motivated to commit homicide and they had their
reasons.
One client I'm thinking about,
she thought it was their moral duty to do this because the person that she paid
it had really hurt their family.
Like not in some trivial way,
but like hurt them as badly as she possibly could,
but there was nothing she could do about it.
There was no legal recourse.
And so she was a very moral person.
In fact,
somewhat I would say
it doesn't matter if she's a very moral person.
This was just driving her crazy.
It's like I have to act,
I have to ask.
I can't just let this person get away with it because it was also ongoing.
Well,
but what are you going to say?
stop thinking about that.
You know,
you could put your thoughts to a more productive use.
It's like,
it's not helpful.
You can't,
you can't help a person like that at all until you put your,
you put yourself in their situation.
You think,
okay,
if I was in that situation and that had happened,
what would I do?
And then the first thing I thought was,
oh,
I'd be having the same kind of burgers fantasies.
So that,
that doesn't seem like it's possible that that's not a great,
so let's see if we can come up with something else.
But the danger there is that you have to put yourself in that situation.
And people don't like to do that because they think,
oh well I'd never have murdered his fantasies.
It's like if you would never have murderous fantasies,
I would actually say there's something wrong with you.
If you're not capable of that.
Then there's like there's a path of you missing.
It's in there man,
and when and when.
When someone's pushing on you at some point in your life and they will,
you better have that reserve capacity or they're just gonna mow you right over
so you could see what this would mean.
It would simply mean that before presenting your own point of view,
it would be necessary for you to really achieve the other speakers frame of
reference to understand his thoughts and feeling so well that you can summarize
them for him.
Sounds simple,
doesn't it?
But if you try it,
you will discover it is one of the most difficult things I've ever tried to do.
However,
once you have been able to see the other's point of view,
your own comments,
we'll have to be drastic and revised.
You will also find the emotion going out of the discussion,
the differences being reduced and those differences which remain being up a
rational and understandable sore.
Roger's thought that courage was a prerequisite for empathic understanding.
It's interesting too,
because you know,
here,
here's a,
here's a question for you.
It's like,
should you trust people
or more specifically,
you know,
should I trust you?
Well,
you might think if you've heard me talk,
you'd think,
well,
there's no way you should trust a person because they're just so full of snakes
and malevolence that it's just absolutely mind boggling.
So why in the world would you ever trust something like that?
Well then you can think about it this way.
There's two kinds of trust.
There's the kind of trust you have when you're too stupid to know better and
that's not trust.
That's naivete.
And that is not a moral virtue.
And there's the kind of trust you have when you know that the person you're
talking to and you are completely full of snakes and you decide as an act of
courage that you're going to trust the person anyways because that of all the
things you could do to help lead them and the discussion towards the light,
that's the most important.
It's like,
I'm going to assume that you know,
our interactions,
your impulse towards the good is going to be victorious.
Now,
isn't it?
If you're interested in this,
you could go online.
You can watch Paul Bernardo,
you remember Old Paul Bernardo.
Okay.
There's videos of Paul Bernardo online when he's talking to a bunch of RCMP
officers and judges.
They're trying to extract some more information from him about some murders that
remained unsolved.
You want to see a psychopath and operation.
You can just watch those videos.
It's amazing.
He,
he runs the meeting like he's the CEO of Apple.
It's amazing.
So,
and that's a problem,
I would say to some degree for the Rogerian approach,
right?
Because,
well,
what about Paul Bernardo,
you know,
is everyone fundamentally oriented towards the good?
Wow.
It's a reasonable presupposition.
Most of the time I think it works better if societies organize themselves
according to that principal because otherwise we know,
for example,
that one of the,
you might think,
what's a natural resource
oil,
right?
For a
bauxite or iron ore or forget about all that.
The fundamental natural resource is trust.
So if you look around the world and you look at economies like Japan for
example,
Japan has no natural resources,
right?
While they're filthy rich.
Why?
Because of the economy is basically predicated on interpersonal trust.
So when there's been some lovely work done in economics regarding precisely
that,
without trust,
your oil just sits in the ground or it leaks out of the pipelines because nobody
welded them property.
You know,
there,
there isn't,
there's no reason to assume that you're going to be able to do anything
cooperative or collaborative.
So trust is a necessity.
If you're really willing to understand a person in this way,
if you're willing to enter his private world is see the way life appears to him.
You run the risk of being changed yourself.
You might see it his way.
You might find yourself influenced in your attitudes or personality.
The risk of being changed is one of the most frightening prospects most of us
can face.
If I enter as fully as I am able into the private world of the neurotic or
psychotic individual,
isn't there a risk that I might become lost in that world?
Most of us are afraid to take that risk.
The great majority of us cannot listen.
We find ourselves compelled to evaluate because listening is too dangerous.
The first requirement is courage and we do not always have it.
Okay,
so it says three o'clock on this,
is that right?
Wow.
That's a good place to stop there.